mit stars & medien mal so etwas glaubt
willkommen beim ein video dieses video
entsteht jetzt wirklich relativ spontan
also ich weiß jetzt nicht was ich sagen
werde so ungefähr halten nur aber nicht
genau
es gibt im grunde euch dieses video
machte der grund ist ganz easy mein
video was am letzten sonntag was ist neu
für den tag ist einfach so krassen ich
habe irgendwie keine schule mehr ich
mache nichts außer youtube und spaß
haben in meinem leben und ich weiß ich
heute ist dienstag glaube genau deswegen
kam vor zwei tagen dieses video was sich
im urlaub gedreht hatte da habe ich mir
gedacht komm also erst mal so ich will
jetzt nicht rumheulen wegen den displays
und so ist okay kein problem es gibt ja
nur wirklich eine sache die ich gern
klarstellen würde weil es viele falsch
aufgefasst haben und das gar nicht so
war
also leute was auf ich meine das ganz
sympathisch ich will jetzt etwas ist
auch scheißegal auf jeden fall bin ich
halt noch zu meinen eltern geflogen den
urlaub und dachte so etwas kannst du da
cooles machen was kannst du dir deinen
abonnenten zeigen ein voller waren so
und da bin ich direkt auf die idee
gekommen kommt verfilmt das ganz einfach
so coole aufnahme da kommen wir auf
jeden fall geile aufnahmen machen ich
war schon öfter und habe mir ein paar
coole sachen ausgeliehen so damit ich
gerne aufnahmen machen kann und wollte
last anhalt zum coolen video zusammen
steigen ich finde das video auch cool
die aufnahmen sind cool ich bin top
zufrieden mit und dann war da halten der
musik hinter hinter diesem video wagt
coole musik hinterlegt ich habe mir
extra also leute fast auf für diese
musik ich habe gekämpft
diese musik dass ich diese musik kriege
weil die wurde von einem dj aus den usa
produziert und ich habe diesen dj
kontaktiert habe ich öfter versucht
damit er das auch wirklich liest und er
hat mir dann letztendlich die
bestätigung dafür gegeben dass ich diese
musik benutzen kann weil du kannst du
nicht einfach so musik benutzen weil ich
fand die musik schon richtig geil und
mich hat heftig gefreut dass sie dies
siek dahinter legen kann genau das video
hat natürlich ich finde es schon ein
bisschen witzig so ich kann darüber
lachen so weil ich finde man sollte auch
mal drüber lachen
auf jeden fall dieses video hat wirklich
jeder eigentlich das video von ihrer
cool aber dann kamen wir es heute
ähnlich es kamen leute die dachten ich
habe die musik gemacht wo ich mir dachte
jungs euer ernst wenn ich diese musik
wenn ich das so könnte ich wäre kein
youtuber ich wäre irgendwann wieder in
den usa ich werde ich in youtube
deutschland unterwegs genau dann wird
wirklich fleißig in den kommentaren
diskutiert ob ich das jetzt wirklich
gesungen habe viele meinen auch das ist
hier mein kurzer ausschnitt
ja leute so hört sich natürlich rap an
das ist ganz klar ob ich weiß nicht ob
ihr in eurem leben noch nie gehört habe
aber das war kein rap ich fand das ging
so mehr in so eine chillige dieb aus
richtung was ihr auch wirklich haben
wollte weil ich feiere lieb aus mega und
ich war wirklich heftig glücklich dass
ich diesen song benutzen darf
und dann gucke ich das video kam online
so ich gucke so hatte soler fünf minuten
dazu wirklich so 786 dislike und ich
will mich jetzt auf keinen fall über den
held unter dem video beschweren auf
jeden fall ihr müsst euch so vorstellen
so ich dachte so jung macht einfach so
ein video und ich dachte wirklich so das
kann kein video sein was displays macht
weil ich meine warum sollte man so was
dislike das einfach cool
zusammengeschnitten ich habe viel arbeit
reingesteckt und ja ich gucke dann halt
und ich hatte 80 display und da habe ich
mich gefragt hey bekommen denn diese
displays oder was ist der auslöser für
weil ich fand in dem video gab es nichts
gewusst zu dislike und dann lese ich in
den kommentaren
und dann lese ich da so ein kommentar
direkt wie den hier zum beispiel der
hatte dann 40 likes wo drinsteht alle
youtuber müssen jetzt rappen oder sonst
was irgendwie und ich dachte mir so
direkt er ist es denn erstmalig habe für
diesen song gekämpft und der song ist
krass da kann mir keiner sagen dass der
song schlecht ist oder dass die personen
die in dem song singt nicht singen kann
weil sie sind irgendwelche leute die
davon leben und das fand ich dann
wirklich ein bisschen schade dass einige
dachten ich hab das gesungen ich wollte
nur ein cooles video für euch
produzieren mit cooler musik die man so
eigentlich feiern kann
und ja das war dann halt irgendwie ein
bisschen doof aber so ist das nun mal
also klarstellung das hat nicht ich
gesungen das soll ich nur ein cooler
beat sein der euch auch gefällt ist mir
leider anschein nicht ganz gelungen aber
gut was ich dann aber auch damit
verbunden ein bisschen schade fand ist
dann halt diese sache so egal ob
youtuber jetzt musik macht weil leute
das ist wirklich gute musik das kann mir
keiner erzählen dass die musik schlecht
ist und viele halt gedacht die kommt von
mir
und die wurde dann halt nur bis leicht
weil sie von mir ist weil ich eigentlich
youtuber bin das fand ich toll schade
aber dann muss man halt mal so
wo diese entwicklung so hinführt so
youtuber und musik vieles ist schlecht
vieles ist okay vieles ist richtig gut
aber irgendwie wird alles sofort und
schlecht verbunden und überall musik im
spiel ist und youtube das passt
überhaupt nicht zusammen dass wir sofort
ein bisschen runter gemacht was ich sehr
schade finden als es sollte nur ein
cooles video sein wo ich dachte das wird
super ich ankommen ist es eigentlich ist
okay aber ich wollte das nur mal kurz
klarstellen
das habe ich nicht verstanden so wie man
denken kann dass ich das gesehen habe
weil leute vergleichbar meine stimme
warte jetzt kommt der beste sänger der
welt
mit stars & medien meist way und jetzt
kommt die gute stimme
und das bin ganz klar ich glaube immer
da sonst und so viel auto schon drauf
bekommt man vielleicht irgendwann in die
nähe
aber ich weiß nicht leute deswegen
schild es ist nicht mein werk als immer
das video wollte ich euch sagen ich
hoffe es ist jetzt klar checkt das video
auf jeden fall noch mal ab wenn es noch
nicht gesehen habe ist ganz oben in der
video beschreibung verlinkt würde mich
freuen wenn ihr diesem video und auch
nach oben da las oder bei dem anderen
video hat ja ansonsten wir sehen uns
morgen wieder morgen kommt um 19 uhr ich
habe es im urlaub noch geschafft mein
bruder ein bis ein bisschen zu kränken
so es ist mir ein bisschen gelogen
allerdings hat sie nicht so gejuckt
leider also das seht ihr morgens kommen
anleihen morgen 19 uhr denke ich mal
irgendwie abends 19 uhr ein hätte das
eigentlich recht habt wir sehen uns hieß
bis morgen